c'est un lieu unique au monde près de
quatre mille parfums sont conservés ici
un trésor inestimable précieusement
gardés dans la cave de l'osmothèque
depuis 25 ans des créations vulnérables
mais véritable joyau de l'histoire je
dirais jusqu'aux années 1950 à peu près
la parfumerie était essentiellement
françaises c'était un vrai patrimoine et
donc on dominait le monde qui n'ont pu
vivre entre paris et grasse et voilà
maintenant aujourd'hui on essaye de
rassembler si l'on peut dire les
chefs-d'oeuvre disparu garants de la
mémoire de la parfumerie l'osmothèque
possède 800 parfum disparu jean pierre
léaud en a lui même refusé deux sens à
partir de formules et de matières
premières un équilibre entre art et
science qui a permis de recréer à
l'identique des parfums mythiques du 20e
siècle
l'idée c'était de se concentrer sur une
thématique pour ses 25 ans et la
thématique et comment faire passer les
parfums à la postérité
dans cette optique là nous avons choisi
25 parfum qui n'existe plus dans les
circuits commerciaux mais dont nous
avons les formules et nous pouvons les
refaire ici à l'osmothèque beaux parfums
pour qu'on peut appeler et qu'elle jure
de sensuel c'est quelque chose qui fait
rêver comme la plupart des parfums
devrait toujours rêver c'est quelque
chose moi qu'il maintient pas
régulièrement la parfumerie un témoin du
passé l'osmothèque et même reconstitué
l'eau de cologne portés par napoléon en
l'établissement organise régulièrement
des conférences olfactives et des
visites pour le public afin de
transmettre cet héritage évanescent la
prochaine a lieu le 6 juillet sur le
thème la grande histoire de la
parfumerie